sources tell CBS News the articles of
impeachment against President Trump
could be delivered to the Senate as soon
as tomorrow and the impeachment trial
could start next Tuesday Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill where House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi meets with fellow Democrats
this morning Nancy what should we expect
to hear from that meeting well we should
learn more Anthony about speaker
Pelosi's timeline for naming House
impeachment managers who would then walk
the articles of impeachment from the
house to the Senate for the trial we
think that that process will take place
within the next couple of days and
here's what it looked like back in 1999
when 13 House Republicans were named as
impeachment managers and then they
essentially served as the lawyers for
the prosecution in the Senate
impeachment trial of President Clinton
after walking the articles across the
Capitol as you see there now who will
the managers be this time we don't know
that's up to Speaker Pelosi but we do
know that the chief lawyer for the
defense will be White House Counsel
Pat's at bologna and there has been some
debate over whether the defense team
should be supplemented with some of the
president's top defenders in the house
like Ohio's Jim Jordan in North
Carolina's Mark meadows but some Senate
Republicans think that bringing in those
house allies would be a mistake that it
would contribute to as one senator put a
quote circus-like atmosphere some Senate
Republicans want to hold a vote this
week to just dismiss the articles of
impeachment altogether and avoid a trial
the president has even endorsed that
idea but at this point Toni it does not
look like they have the votes for that
all right Nancy thank you very much
you